[Music]
there's judy in motion again
sometimes when you're playing man-to-man
coverage you're depending on the
quarterback to miss this throw or
slow him down approaching the red zone
again the tide
harris flares out of the backfield
tacoma
oh what a fake and touchdown alabama
the outside quarterback draw you got
bozeman in front
he nails this guy and then tiger malloy
just makes
the safety whiff micah abernathy missed
him by about two yards after he put his
foot in the
ground in both games they've never
started a year with three straight
50-point games
still
[Applause]
wesley mcgriff said we cannot give up
the middle of the field and we've got to
know where four is
with nick saban that gravitate towards
him instead of away from him yeah nick
says everybody runs away from him
this guy's special he's different off
the field down the middle of fearless
jerry judy
who else for the score 81 yards
of a second play from scrimmage there's
creative ways that mike locksley will
release his wide receivers and he knows
i asked him yesterday
about free release with jerry judy says
i'm not sure why
people keep letting him run free down
the field only one way to get that done
you gotta recruit yep
depends a blitz off the corner kind of
allah steps away from it and throws deep
metal man there
got him touchdown henry ruggs he knows
it's bearing down on a sack right here
he lets it go at the last second when he
knows he's got the touchdown
and ruggs gets one and he took a shot
late
tonga by loa slides off goes deep for
judy
on the money touchdown alabama
what a throw by tua perfectly
tossed to judy for his seventh touchdown
he grabs that safety
and as a result you have one-on-one on a
post over the top with jerry judy
take what they give us already in tiger
territory here comes the blitz
talking about what we're going along
judy's got it touchdown
there's the explosive player bottom of
the screen right here there's the
match-up
that's been the match-up all day
auburn's been willing to play man
coverage
and judy with a perfect throw puts it
into the end zone
see if devin white comes flying in he's
trying to talk about olaf flushed out of
the pocket he'll run with it he's got
the first down and more
still on the run he is gone everybody
had their back turn
you get past the rush look at that lsu
defender in the top of the screen there
running away from two
tight end smith motions in two has got
it
spins away throws to the ends and a
risky throw caught for a touchdown
there are some flags in late it was judy
on the receiving end
then decides to come in commit and then
comes in and hits him low
just under six minutes another first
down alabama
scanning the field he had all kinds of
time and eyes running out of it he's
still going to rip it down
field touchdown devonte
smith remember the a
m game 59 to nothing we're getting close
yes and he keeps his
wits about him what up it's your boy
adam lefkow do you like that content i
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report